est ce qu'à votre avis il exerçait des
missions d'organisation de déplacement
exclusivement ou est-ce qu'ils
exerçaient des missions de police et de
sécurité
alors monsieur le sénateur je pense que
vous avez auditionné beaucoup de monde
très longue amant monsieur b dallas
matin et qu'il a eu tout le loisir de
répondre à cette question
moi je me réserve le droit de ne pas y
répondre
très bien mais puisque vous le côtoyer
que vous le connaissiez vous savez
peut-être une idée sur la question j'ai
forcément x games hervé vous savez dire
la vérité juge je dis la vérité mais je
ne suis pas monsieur bénard je suis
monsieur kraz oui d'accord mais là ce
avait une connaissance du sujet bien sûr
que je vous pose et vous pouvez répondre
en toute sincérité
ça me concerne en rien monsieur le
sénateur oui au fond monsieur mais je
crains si vous estimez que de votre
balcon de l'endroit où vous étiez vous
ne pouviez pas apprécier la réalité de
la fonction de monsieur benalla je ne
connais pas sa fiche de poste je n'ai
pas lu son son contrat de travail donc
je ne vais pas me risquer à dire des
approximations
très bien mais le temps est monsieur le
président excusez moi d'insister vous
étiez à l'elysée vous le connaissiez
bien vous pouvez nous dire si ce qu'il
faisait et on nous à vous savez on nous
a tout dit et donc nous devons
rechercher la vérité
on nous a présenté je l' ai déjà dit
plusieurs fois comme une sorte vous
savez de gentils organisateurs de
voyages comme dans une organisation qui
célèbre il est très gentil je vous le
confirme non mais je
je ne porte pas de jugement mois sur ce
sujet et voilà une information en tout
cas que vous nous avez donné on nous a
aussi on a eu des éléments qui ont
montré qu'ils avaient des fonctions de
sécurité à commencer par le permis de
port d'armes
donc vous vous saviez bien les choses
comme un bout ne pas vous dire je ne
savais rien vous savez bien que ce n'est
pas rare et monsieur le sénateur même si
je sais c'est chose je ne vous y
répondrait pas très bien écoutez je
prends acte de votre réponse